Hello and welcome the fire of learning the French,
the surrender monkeys of Europe.
The Nation only exists because the British and the Americans saved it so many
times.
If you want to know what the French flag looks like,
well here it is for sale.
French army rifle,
never fired,
dropped once,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Every nation has its negative stereotypes and for France,
one of the main ones is,
well,
you get the picture,
but how deserving are the French actually have the name coward?
Do they really have a poor military record or is this stereotype really just not
very substantial?
In this video,
we're going to take a look at the French military history and determine the
authenticity of the insult.
So as you may know,
the origin of associating France with cowardice and surrendering comes from the
events of the Second World War.
On June 22nd,
1940 the French government surrendered to the Nazi.
Germans and Germany subsequently occupied the north of the country while the
south was governed by a puppet government.
Regardless of whatever conclusion we come to in this video,
we can admit that this surrender was in fact embarrassing and to the allies at
the time.
Demoralizing.
However,
why was this particular surrenders so well known and embarrassing?
Was it because the French were expected to a performed better?
France is a very old country.
There is debate as to when exactly the nation itself arose,
but the foundations of the nation begin as early as four 81 eight d under
Clovis,
the first king of the Franks.
This makes friends essentially the oldest,
major nation and Europe.
Secondly,
France is the third largest nation in Europe after Russia and Ukraine.
The simple fact that France has endured for so long and held onto so much
territory,
hotly contested territory,
mind you suggest that they are a people with a backbone.
However,
what did the actual statistics say in the words of the British historian,
Niall Ferguson.
Frances participated in 50 of the 125 major European wars fought since 1495 more
than Austria at 47 and England at 43 as an example,
in 168 battles fought since 387 BC.
He's a including the Gauls as French.
I'm not sure if that's really fair,
but anyway,
to continue here and the 168 battle spots since 387 BC,
the French have one 109 drawn 10 and lost 49 and this is of course,
major battles.
This makes France the most successful military power in European history in
terms of number of battles fought and won.
Many of these wars were some of the most important in European and in fact world
history in seven 32 for example,
at the battle of tour,
the French King Charles Martel,
the Umayyad Caliphate,
the saving Christian Europe from a Muslim invasion in 10 66 the Normans,
a group then consisting of a mix of French and vikings conquered England and
laid the foundations for the modern English nation.
The French were some of the main participants of the Crusades and a major power
throughout the middle ages.
The French colonial empire would extend across large parts of the world,
including much of North America,
Africa,
parts of the Middle East,
India and East Asia,
and the 17th seventies the American revolution was greatly dependent on French
intervention.
In fact,
French intervention may have been the deciding factor of the war under Napoleon.
The French empire would extend from Spain to Russia.
The French were a major player in the conflicts of the 19th century,
and we're a main cause for victory in the first world war.
This is just a brief overview of some of Francis major military successes.
There have of course been many major defeats as well.
The victorious.
Eventually in the hundred years war over England,
the war or wars really strained France greatly and it was often on the losing
side.
The French and Indian war was a disaster.
Napoleon's empire eventually fell apart.
World War II,
as I said,
did not go so well,
et cetera.
However,
from the Middle Ages to the modern day,
the French army was one of the best equipped in all of Europe,
and in fact,
oftentimes in the world and many ways as well.
They laid the foundation for the Organization of the modern military and
general.
Many of the words used in modern warfare derived from French vocabulary such as
army artillery,
Captain Cavalry charge as espionage,
General Lieutenant Lance Marines,
maneuver,
military,
mine,
naval parachute,
pilot platoon,
regimented soldier and trench.
And so what's the case with World War II?
Well,
France was not the only nation to surrender to the Germans and of the nations,
which did surrender friends house as one of the longest.
Among them though the German military strength at the time and blitzkrieg tactic
claimed many nations.
Poland for example,
surrendered.
And a little over a month,
Belgium fell in 18 days.
The Netherlands fell in four days for the more following the surrender of the
French people,
even if not the government held out against the Nazis through the French
Resistance.
And so in conclusion,
from this short video,
the image of the French as cowardly is definitely not deserved.
And as a matter of fact,
the French have had one of the finest militaries to exist in all of history.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
we should have take out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.